[THEME MUSIC]
SYLVANO LUCIANI: Welcome
to Personalize Actions
for the Google Assistant.
Thanks for being here.
I'm Sylvano Luciani.
I work in the
Assistant and Actions
on Google Developer
Relations team.
ADAM DAWES: Hi there.
My name's Adam Dawes, and
I'm a product manager.
And we build Identity
tools for developers.
SYLVANO LUCIANI: So in
the next half an hour
or so we're going to present
you some of the functionality
that the Actions
on Google Platform
provides to you to
personalize your actions.
But first, I'd like
to briefly talk
about why is it important
to personalize your action,
and let's start by looking
at the Google Assistant.
The Assistant is an
assistive technology
that is at the center of an
ecosystem of more than 500--
sorry, millions
devices, and it's
there to help users
to get things done,
things like get entertained,
listening to some music,
or playing some games, get
informed by reading or watching
some news, learn new
recipes, and so on.
Actions on Google
is the platform
that allows you to
extend the Assistant.
You can add your own actions
so that you can provide help
for a knowledge domain where
you think you are an expert,
and you can provide
value to the user.
You can connect with new
users across all the devices
that we've seen,
and you can innovate
by adding conversational
interface that
can make some of
the tasks very easy,
just a straight voice command.
So thinking about
this, there are
two aspects where it's important
to personalize your action.
The aspect, number one,
is for some of the things
that you might want to do, like
for example present some music
that a user can listen to to be
entertained, if you know more
about their preferences
and their tastes,
you can provide them with
music that will be more in line
with that expectation
and that will fulfill
their intent in a better way.
The other aspect to
consider is we've
seen that your actions
can be involved
across different
devices, and so you
want to be able, if
the user has expressed
some preferences on, for
example, a smart speaker,
honor those preferences
also when they start
another conversation with your
action on a different device,
like a phone or a smart
display, where you will also
be able to provide a better
experience because now you
can also show visuals to provide
a better output to the user.
So we are going to look
at three main buckets
that I've already
almost mentioned.
The first one is what is
the platform providing to us
so that we can learn something
more about the Assistant user?
Then we'll see how we can
store this information
in the current conversation that
we are having with the user,
or in all the conversation
that we might have
with the user, which means
future conversation and also
conversation on
different devices.
Finally, Adam will talk about
adding Identity to your action.
That can be a
requirement in cases
where, for example,
the user wants
to know where the next payment
for a certain service is due.
If you are the
service provider, you
need to know who they
are on your system.
You need to authenticate
them so that you can actually
retrieve the correct
information for their account.
So starting from learning
more about the Assistant user,
I'm going to introduce
Helper Intents.
Helper Intents
are a core concept
of the Assistant platform.
You can request to the
Assistant to momentarily take
over the conversation
so that you
can perform some special
tasks on your behalf.
Some of these special
tasks are things
like you can ask to
transfer the conversation
to a different surface with
different capabilities.
If, for example, you
started a conversation
on a smart speaker, you want
to show a visual to the user,
you can ask the
conversation to be
transferred to a phone
or another device that
can show the visual.
Or you can even [INAUDIBLE]
into an Android app.
If, for example, the user
[INAUDIBLE] request the task
that you think it's not very--
doesn't provide a
good user experience
with a voice interface,
and you'd rather
pan to your existing
Android app.
In this talk, we are going to
look at a subset of the Helpers
that allow you to ask to obtain
some information from the user.
This information can be
of two different types.
One is you can ask, to the user,
their consent for the Assistant
to share some information with
your action, like the user
name or the device
location-- the location
of the device where that
conversation is happening.
Date and time and
place and location
are rather a way of asking
an input to the user.
I need a date for you.
If, for example, your actions
allow users to book services,
and you want to know when
they want the service,
or a place or location if
you are arranging a delivery,
and you want to know
where to deliver the goods
that are part of
the transaction.
So starting from the first one,
how can we get the username?
In this slide, what
you see on your left
is a simulation
of a conversation
that I did on a test app that
I wrote, and on the right,
you can see some of the
code from our Node.JS client
library.
It's not the complete
code for the action.
It's just the bits that
are relevant to the helpers
that I'm showing, and
you can see how it works.
So the first, you ask the
permission, the permission
to get the name of the user,
and you provide the context
that it's very important
because with the context,
you are explaining to the
user why you need the name.
How is your service
going to be better
if you obtain that information?
So in this case, I'm
just telling them, hey,
I want to address
you by your name.
In the Assistant, they
covered the conversation.
Ask the user, can I share this
information with the action?
If there is a positive
reply, then you've
got access to the
name, and you can
use it straight to greet
the user by their name.
If not, you need
to deal with it.
Acknowledge that they
didn't want to share
the information with you.
Try to provide the best
service that you can.
This next slide is showing
to you the role JSON API.
So if you're not using
the client library,
and instead, you're using
the conversation web book,
this is how you
request the permission.
So you can see the
intent name is Action,
that intent of
permission, and then
there's a bag of
parameters that can go.
They are different with--
for every helper
intent, and they
are defined in a value
spec that is just saying,
this request might contain
this type of field.
And you can see the context
where I'm explaining
why I want that information,
This is showing you, in the
following request that you
receive from the Assistant--
if the user consented
to give you access
to the information,
this is how you receive it.
Location is very similar because
it's exactly the same intent.
It's an intent that is called
permission, and one again--
once again, the Assistant
is asking the user,
can I share the location of
your device with the action?
If the user replies yes, you
get access to the location,
and now in this case, you
could resolve the latitude
then the longitude to
the place where they are,
and then find something that
it's near that location.
JSON is pretty similar.
If you see, there's
only a different value
for the type of permission
that we're asking.
And one thing that
you can notice now
is Permissions is
an array, which
means if you want to ask for
both the name and the location
at the same time, you can do it.
You can just ask for multiple
permissions in that array.
This is how you get the location
if the user consent to give it
to you.
Now, Date/Time is slightly
different, as I mentioned,
because in this case,
we are not anymore
asking the user if the Assistant
can share some information
without action.
We are directly asking the
user, can you give me a date--
a date value?
And the most powerful
thing, when you do this
through the Assistant,
is we can resolve
ways of specifying a date there
are not just a date format.
So if you look at
the example, when
would you like to
reserve the table?
I reply tomorrow.
The Assistant resolves tomorrow
to what tomorrow is at the time
that we are having
the conversation.
Another thing that you might
notice is, in this case,
we have three prompts.
There's an initial prompt.
There is the reason why we
want to ask that information.
But there's also a date
and time additional prompt
that the Assistant
uses if it gets
only parts of the information
that you need from the user.
So if I only specify a
date, like in the case
of the example, where
I just said tomorrow,
the Assistant will
ask, what time,
using the prompt
that you specify.
And once you have that
information, you can access it.
In the case of the
Node.JS client library,
represent it as an
out of date object.
Again, not very different.
This is the JSON,
so what is changing
is just the bag of parameters
that you are passing
when you ask for this helper.
And the value that you get in
this case from the Assistant--
it's a little longer because you
have the date part and the time
part.
The last helper that I
want to present to you
is the place and
location helper.
Again, this is not
any more asking
the user can they share
your current location
with the action.
It's asking the user, give me
a place, give me a location.
Again, you can see that
if you use this helper,
we can resolve things like
the public name of a place.
So for example, when the
action asks, where would
you like to pick it up, and I
reply Shoreline Amphitheatre,
what you actually get
is the whole address--
Shoreline Amphitheatre,
Amphitheatre Parkway, and so
on.
Not a lot of difference, again.
You already know this API.
It's all-- it's a very
familiar API by now.
The only things
that are changing
are the type of
parameters that you
can send along with the helper
and the name of the helper
itself.
And the request, in
this case, you've
got a little bit more
info because you also
got the formatted address,
the public name, and some more
stuff.
Why is it not working?
In this example,
where you have--
I have site to site--
two different situations.
The first one is the place.
We've seen how we can
resolve a public place.
You asked for
Shoreline Amphitheatre.
You just get the address.
But the sample on the right is
showing something different.
It's showing a location.
A location is something
that a user defines in maps,
and it's private to them--
for example, my home
or my workplace.
And so in the example on
the right, when I ask Work,
the Assistant requests
again another type
of consent, which is can I
share with the action what Work
is for you?
And only if the user
says yes, then you
can get that resolved address.
If you want to see more about
helpers, we have a sample--
github.com/actions on
google/dialogflow helper
intents nodejs.
It shows usage of
all the helpers
that are available
on the platform.
There's a couple of
other information
that can be useful that we
can find in every request
without the need of requesting
any specific helper.
The first one is just there,
and it's called the lastSeen,
and it's just the timestamp
of the last interaction
with the user.
The first time they use it as
an interaction with your action,
it will be undefined.
After that, you will
always have the timestamp
of the last interaction.
This means that you can use
it, for example, to greet them
differently.
You can just say
Welcome the first time,
and then if the time
stamp has a value,
you can say Welcome Back because
you know that they visited
your action at least once.
And you can even do
more complex stuff,
like you could calculate
how much time has passed
since the last time
they visited you,
and depending on
whether you consider
that range to be a
short or a long time,
you can greet them and reengage
with them in a different way.
The other one that it's
interesting for all of you that
have Android apps that allow
users to purchase or subscribe
to entitlements is you
can connect your action
to your Android app.
It's just configuration in
the console and verification
that you actually
own the Android app,
and then all the entitlements
that that user has bought
on your Android App on Play will
be available in every request.
And this is an example
of how you will see it.
In this case, I'm
just giving you
a JSON example because
in the client library,
we basically just build
a JavaScript object that
contains all this information.
So this was it for some ways of
learning more about the user.
What about storing information
in the conversation?
We've said that it's
important that we can do that
so that we can give a more
personalized experience
inside a conversation,
but also across all
the different conversation
that the user can
have with your action.
The first concept that I'd
like to introduce to you
is the conversation token.
The conversation
token-- it's available
only if you're using
an action, SDK action,
and it's a field of the
response and the request defined
in the conversation
[INAUDIBLE] API.
It's just a screen
that we recirulate.
If you've write to
it, we will send back
what you've written
in the next request.
If you change it,
we will do it again.
The main catch is its value.
It's always initialized
to an empty string
at the beginning of
the conversation,
so the lifespan is only
the current conversation,
and it-- all the
values that you've
stored in there will be cleared
when the conversation ends.
So you can use it
for some improvements
where those
improvements make sense
only in the life cycle of
the current conversation
that you're having.
One example of how to write
the value, in the first case,
I'm just writing
a simple string.
In the second case,
what I'm doing is,
because I want to use a
more structured approach,
I'm serializing a JSON
object to a string
so that I can get a
representation that
contains an object.
An exam-- sorry,
on Dialogflow, you
don't have access to
the conversation token,
but you have the
same functionality
expressed with a more
powerful abstraction called
output context.
And the reason why I say
that it's more powerful
is you can have more
than one output context.
Each one has a name, and you
can identify them by name.
You can set the lifespan
in terms of conversation
for which that data
will be available,
and it already provides an
interface that gives you
access to a structured value.
So to see an example
of an output context,
you can see that output
context add an array.
In this case, I have only
one, but I could have more.
It's identified by
a very long name.
The lifespan count is
five turns in this case,
and then I'm writing an object
for what are the value that I
want to store in this context.
If you use the client
library or Node.JS,
we gave you the best of both
worlds because what we do
is we provide you
an abstraction.
Data is just an object.
You write whatever you
want with the object,
and then depending on whether
your action is an action
SDK or a Dialogflow,
we do the right thing
at the low level using the
conversation token in one case,
or the output
context in the other.
To see an example of
how you could use it,
let's say you have some
music that you want to play.
The user asks, I want
to listen to some music.
You can ask them, do
you want a random genre?
Do you want a specific genre?
If they give you
one, you can save it
so that for the rest
of the conversation,
you can keep giving them
music coming from that genre.
In advanced use
case, you could also
have a counter where you
count how many songs for that
genre you've been
giving to the user.
And when they reach a certain
point, let's say 10 songs,
you ask do you still
want this genre,
or do you want to change?
In some other cases,
the conversation token
doesn't work because,
let's say you
want to store the preferences
for an action that is giving
you weather forecast,
and you want
to save the zip or an area code
to identify the area for where
they want the forecast.
If you save this in the
conversation token, what
happens is that value is lost
at the next conversation,
so you would be asking
again, what is your zip,
and that's not a
good experience.
And that's where user
storage comes into play,
and this slide might seem
very familiar to you.
It's exactly the same API
of conversation token,
so you already know
how to use this.
It's a field of
response requests.
It's a string.
You can write just a screen or
serialize a structure of data.
We will recirculate it
across all the conversation
that you're having
with the user--
future conversation,
conversation
on different devices.
The main difference
is the content
can be clear only by the
app itself or by the user,
and we will see how to do
it in a couple of slides.
So this is exactly
the same example
that I had for the
conversation token.
The only thing that has changed
is the name of the field.
Now, I'm using user
storage, and that
means I have access
to a bigger lifespan.
Going back to the
example of storing
that zip, now that we store
it in the user storage,
if I started this conversation
on a smart speaker,
save the zip, the moment I ask
for the forecast from my phone,
the action will
know the zip code
and won't need to
ask for it again.
That said, this is how
you [INAUDIBLE] the value.
You raise the Boolean.
If you're using
the client library,
you set the value of the
storage to an empty object,
and we clear it for you.
Last thing I have to say
about the user storage
is very important.
This is mostly like a cookie,
and so there are some countries
that have strong regulations
about obtaining consent
from the user before you
can save or read data
from the user storage.
So if you're operating
one of those country,
make sure that you use the
Confirmation Helper, that
is an helper that allows you
to ask something to the user
and get the yes or no
request before you actually
start writing or reading
data from the user storage.
And with that, it's now time
for Adam to talk about Identity.
ADAM DAWES: All right,
thank you, Silvano.
So user storage is
a terrific feature
to be able to hold state
and build continuity
with a user across
multiple conversations.
It works a lot like a
cookie or HTML5 storage
might in a browser.
But we know that
isn't always enough,
so let me talk a
little bit about how
you can use Identity
to further deepen
your experience with the user.
So the first thing that
you get with Identity
is you get to know
who the user is.
You get to know her
name, her email address,
and you get access to
her profile picture.
This allows you to build
a direct relationship
with the user, where
you can engage her
via email outside of the
context of using your app.
The next thing that
Identity provides
is the ability to have
a consistent experience
across multiple devices
and on different platforms.
So with user storage, you're
able to keep application state
and user preferences,
but all of that data
is stored in Google's
cloud and only
available to your
conversational action.
But with Identity, now you can
store all of the user's data
on your own back end, and
whether or not the user
comes back via your
mobile app, the web,
or your conversational
action, you'll
be able to reset the
state for the user
and get her going where she
left off the last time she
used your service.
And finally, with
Identity, now that you
have all of her data
stored on your back end,
Identity can now help you secure
that data so only the user
has access to it,
and nobody else does.
So the Actions on
Google Cloud Platform
has supported Identity from
the very beginning with OAuth
based account linking.
But the problem that we found
is that when a user engages
with your action via
voice, the only way
to be able to do that
account linking experience
was to punt the
user to the phone
and get the user to
then go to your website,
log in, and complete
the linking experience.
These kinds of cross device
flows are super difficult,
and as you can imagine, the
conversion rate is pretty low.
That's why we're super
excited to announce
the developer preview of Google
Sign In for the Assistant.
It provides a way
for your existing
users or your new users to
sign into your app completely
via voice without needing to--
without needing to leave the
context of the conversation.
Inside Google Sign In
on other platforms,
we're actually able
to automatically log
users in if they've
previously used
your service on a different
device or another platform.
Google Sign In for
Assistant comes in two
different developer modes.
In multi-platform mode, we layer
Google sign in on top of OAuth
based account linking.
This is what provides this
seamless voice based account
linking experience
for Google users,
yet still maintains
a path for users
that registered with your
service with another identity,
be it a Hotmail account or
a Yahoo account or something
like that.
Now, for Assistant
only developers,
we're especially
excited about what
Google Sign In for Assistant
is going to be able to do.
We know that there are a lot
of Assistant only developers
out there, and we've heard you--
that Identity and account
linking is a heavy lift just
to get started on the platform.
So now, with Google
Sign In for Assistant,
you're able to rely
completely on Google to manage
all of your users' identity.
That means you don't
need to build an account
system of your own,
and it's totally cool
if you've never
even heard of OAuth.
Let's take a look at how one of
these Assistant only developers
is planning on using the tool.
So Starbutter AI
was founded by four
self-described
personal finance geeks
who love to argue with each
other about the best way
to manage their
personal finances
and look for financial
services products.
They all found themselves
with a similar experience,
where their friends and
families would inundate them
with questions about the
best credit cards to get
or how to get a mortgage.
It was through this
experience that they realized
that the best way to recommend
financial services products was
to get to know the user
through a question and answer
kind of dialogue.
This is why they
founded the company
and are investing so big
into AI and are building
on the Assistant platform.
And they're doing great.
Just last year,
they won an award
for being one of the top actions
on the Assistant platform.
But to offer the kind
of personalized advice
that will keep users coming
back again and again,
and that's relevant for
them, Starbutter really
needs a user's identity.
Last week, we gave them
access to Google Sign
In for the Assistant, so let's
take a look at their demo app
to see what they're thinking
about in terms of getting
set up with this new feature.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Talk to Mortgage Helper Demo.
- All right, getting the test
version of Mortgage Helper
Demo.
- Hi, I'm Morgan, an
artificial intelligence
assistant for home loans.
I analyze millions
of data points
to finding you
the best mortgage.
Want to compare loan
offers or calculate
how much you can borrow?
- Calculate how
much I can borrow.
- To compare home
loan offers, I'll
need your basic info to create
a new Mortgage Helper Demo
account.
If you want more details,
say Tell Me More.
Can I have your name, email
address, and profile picture
from Google?
- Yes.
- Great.
Alex, I created a new
Mortgage Helper Demo account
using your Google account.
You're all set.
- All right, Alex.
Are you purchasing a property,
or are you refinancing
a property you already own?
[END PLAYBACK]
ADAM DAWES: All right,
wasn't that so much better?
The user was able
to create an account
without leaving the context
of their conversation.
And Starbutter said
that it was super easy
for them to get set up, so let's
take a look behind the scenes
at what's going on.
So the first thing to
know about Google Sign
In for the Assistant is that
it operates like Google Sign
In on all other platforms.
The same principles apply, where
you want to get information
about who the user is.
Google presents
a UI for the user
to make a decision
about whether or not
they want to reveal their
basic profile info to your app.
If the user says yes, then
we generate an ID token
and hand it back to your client.
Now, let's take a look at
one of these ID tokens.
So an ID token is
just a JSON web token,
and that's basically a
dictionary of JSON which
is cryptographically
signed by Google,
so you can be sure that the
information inside the token
is authentic.
Inside the token, you'll
see all of the information
that you need in order
to be able to make
a decision about whether
to link the account
or create a new
account for the user.
So that includes the user's
name, their profile picture,
and their email
address, as well as
the Google specific identifier
that's unique to that user.
You'll also notice at
the top of this screen,
there's the AUD field.
That's short for Audience.
This is also a super
important field
because that protects the
security of your user's data.
It's what prevents another
app from getting an ID
token for that Google
user and replaying
that token against your
back end to get access
to that user's data.
Let's take a look
at what Starbutter
had to do to get this
set up in their action.
So the first thing
that they needed to do
was to go to the Actions
on Google Developer console
and go to the Identity and
account linking section.
And there, they configured
that they used Google Sign
In as their linking type.
Next, they need to
update their action,
so first, they need to
initialize their client ID.
This is what comes
back in the audience
and protects the user's data.
And then they need to
find the right time
to be able to ask the user
to log in and provide consent
to give their
account information.
Now, Starbutter did
that relatively early,
and you're going to want to
be thoughtful about where
you do this.
It's generally not best practice
to immediately ask the user
to sign in when they
open your action,
so think about that carefully.
And then finally, the last thing
that Starbutter needed to do
was to be able to
handle the resolution.
Now, this can break two ways--
the user can agree to provide
their profile information,
or they can decide not to.
If they agree, then
we'll be able to return
that whole set of JSON that
comes back in the ID token,
and then you'll be able to
extract the user's email
address or their
Google identifier,
and then you can start keying
data on your back end based
on that user's identity.
If the user decides not to
provide that information,
then you're going to want
to handle that gracefully.
You're going to want to be
able to explain to the user
the benefit of logging
in, and if they still
decide that they don't want
to share their information,
you're going to try to forward
the conversation and give--
be useful to the user even
without knowing who they are.
Now, let's shift back to
the other developer type--
the multi-platform developer.
So for them, things
are a little bit more
complicated because they
want to be able to support
two types of users--
both the Google user
as well as any user
who may have registered
with their service
given another identity provider
like Microsoft or Outlook.
So for them, they need to
be able to have that path
to be able to connect to
data for both user types.
Now, I understand it may feel
like a little bit of a caveat
that only Google users are able
to get this voice based account
linking experience,
but I want to stress
that it's still going
to be super impactful
for your action.
We know that you've invested
a lot of time and energy
to build a great
experience for users,
and so we want to make sure
that we bring as many users
through that front door.
And so by having Google users
get this streamlined voice
experience, that's
going to bring many more
users to enjoy all the benefits
that your action provides.
So let's take another
look at an action that
is on multiple platforms.
So this is Itcher,
and their goal in life
is to be able to answer that
age old question of what
movie or TV show
should I watch tonight.
So they've built a personalized
recommendation that's
available on iOS, Android, web,
and the Assistant platform,
and they've offered many
different ways for users
to sign in via Google,
Facebook, username, password,
even Twitter.
So now, it's pretty
self-evident that Itcher really
needs a user's identity.
They can't store users
likes and dislikes
and make meaningful
recommendations
without being able to have
a consistent experience
across time and across devices.
So let's see how
they're planning
on using Google Sign In for
Assistant with their demo app.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Talk to Itcher.
- OK, let's get the
test version of Itcher.
- To get started, I'll
need your basic info
to personalize your experience.
If you want more details,
say, tell me more.
Can I have your name, email
address, and profile picture
from Google?
- Yes.
- Great.
So now, I can check to see if
you have an account with us.
Just a sec.
I found your account, Alex.
Your account is now
linked to Google.
- Hey, this is Itcher.
I can give you personalized
movie, TV show, and book
recommendations you'll love.
How can I help?
[END PLAYBACK]
ADAM DAWES: All right
so that was also
a much, much better experience.
That-- in the
background, we were
able to detect whether
or not Alex already
had an account with Itcher and
seamlessly make the experience.
So how does Itcher
create that experience,
and other multi-platform
developers, with Google Sign
In for Assistant?
So first, just like
Starbutter, they
need to go to their actions
on Google Developer console,
but in this case, they
pick OAuth and Google
Sign In as the way that they
want to do account linking.
Next, they do exactly
like Starbutter.
They find the right
time in the conversation
to ask the user to
sign in, and then this
is where things get a
little bit different.
So in that interaction,
we went and we
went to do a discovery
to whether or not
that account already exists.
So in order to make
that happen, Starbutter,
and in this example,
the Food Bot app,
they created a separate
API, a separate REST API,
from their conversational
action fulfillment endpoint.
So we call this endpoint
the token endpoint,
and it allows us to do account
discovery and creation.
So the way the logic
of this endpoint works
is pretty straightforward.
So we ask the user
whether or not
they want to sign into the app.
If they say yes, then
we generate an ID token,
and we send it to
the token endpoint.
Food Bot, in this case,
validates the ID token,
and then they extract
the user's email address
and do a look up on
their account database.
If they find that
user already exists,
then they'll link the account
by taking the Google identifier
and storing that for the user.
And then they'll also
generate their own credential
and return that to Google.
Google will store
that credential
and then return that in
every turn of conversation
back to the Food
Bot app, and that's
how it will be able to keep
state on who the user is.
Now if, in that look
up on whether or not
that user already exists, that
a user doesn't exist, then
Food Bot will return
an error saying
I've never heard of that user.
So then what Google does is
we look up Food Bot's settings
and see if they want to support
account creation via voice.
Not all apps want to do that.
Sometimes, the
registration process
requires that they
gather more information
than just the name
and email address,
or maybe that they want to make
sure that the user has really
evaluated their privacy
policy in terms of service.
But if they do
decide that they want
to do voice based
account creation,
then we'll ask the user
do you want to create
an account with Food Bot?
If the user says yes, we'll then
again hit this token endpoint,
and the token
endpoint will again
validate the request
as coming from Google
and then extract the name, email
address and profile picture
and store that
information as a new user
in their user database.
And then they'll
also create a token
and return that
to Google to store
and then respond with
every turn of conversation
to keep that context.
Now, if Food Bot
decides that they
don't want to do voice
based account creation,
or the user decides
that they don't want
to create a new
account, they want
to go and log into their
existing account that
might be based on a Yahoo
or a Microsoft Identity,
then we fall back to the regular
OAuth based account flow,
where we punt the
user to the phone,
and they manually log
in via their web site.
And then Food Bot returns a
credential back to Google.
This ensures that all
users are able to complete
the account linking flow,
and all the Google users
have this streamlined
experience.
So that's pretty much it.
It's really easy to take
advantage of Google Sign
In for the Assistant,
whether you're
an Assistant only developer
or a multi-platform developer.
The developer preview
is available today.
Just go out-- go and check
out the actions on developer--
actions on Google
Developer docs and look
for the Identity section.
Now, as a recap,
Sylvano talked to you
about how you can build a
more personalized experience
with the user by using Helper
Intents to get permission
to get the user's name,
location, and time.
He also talked about
how to use the request
info to see when the user
last used your action
and whether or not the user
has already purchased info
from your surface
via the Play Store.
Next, he talked about how to
store information and build
continuity with the user using
the conversational token, as
well as user storage.
And then I lead
you through how you
can use Google Sign
In for Assistant
to get the user's
identity and email
address and the power of
voice based account creation
and account linking.
And for Actions only
developers, now they
don't even need to have
their own account system.
So we know your time
is very valuable.
We would love to hear what you
thought of our presentation,
so please navigate back
to the I/O schedule,
find this session,
and give us a rating.
And if you want more
information, please go online.
We've got helpful-- docs that
describes Sylvano's experiences
and the best practices,
and you can learn more
about Google Sign In for
Assistant in the developer docs
section.
We'll also be across the
way at the Assistant Code
Lab and igloo tent, so please
come and ask us questions.
Thank you very much for
you attention, and have
a great last day at I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]